good morning everyone and welcome to the
big data to knowledge a guide to the
fundamentals of data science I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Southern
California based here at the bd2k
training coordinating center and I'd
like to welcome all of you to our second
volume if you will in our series of data
science seminars focused on the
fundamentals of data science and we are
very excited to be beginning this season
with a lecture by Jonathan Entwistle
from IBM talking about collaborative and
scalable open-source data science and
just a few words about Jonathan Jonathan
has worked in the federal government
data science community for over a decade
working with large programs within the
NIH within the Food and Drug
Administration as well as CMS he holds a
master's degree in predictive analytics
from Northwestern University he
specializes in data science at scale
leveraging technologies such as Hadoop
and spark it was in Maryland with his
family and so I understand he routinely
discusses data science at dinner with
his statistician wife and his
two-year-old son so it's good that he's
helping the next generation of young
scientists in data science so without
further delay I'd like to invite
Jonathan to give his presentation and
invite you to send in any questions that
you have by the little chat feature that
you can see in the go-to webinar panel I
will go in trying to select various
questions to ask Jonathan at the end and
I'm sure Jonathan will pass on his
contact information and be available for
questions and comments offline at any
time that you want to reach out to him
again just one final thing is that this
year we're going to be having a series
of these lectures we're gonna be trying
to do them regularly on Fridays at this
time we're going to try and steer around
the holidays and so you may find at
least initially where things are
interrupted by holidays we understand
those are important family times and
times when you'll all be
way but then certainly things will pick
up steam and then we also ask you if you
have any ideas for speakers for our
seminar series so please reach out to to
us and make those suggestions we'd love
to have them without further delay let
me have Johnathan take it over we're
excited to hear from you Jonathan thank
you good afternoon to everyone on the
East Coast and good morning to those of
you joining me from the west coast again
my name is Jonathan Entwistle and you
saw my contact information up there I
actually do primarily work with the u.s.
federal government including all HHS but
I've got a lot of experience spanning
all kinds of different spectrums so if
there's focus on we want to talk about
cybersecurity or other things like that
I'm happy to do so the agenda for this
presentation is really going to focus on
a healthcare use case with some real
data and you'll be able to follow along
with me if you're so inclined by going
to data science that ibm.com and you'll
be invited to join what's called the
data science experience I highly
recommend doing so so you can move along
interactively with me if you want
although obviously you don't have to so
for those of you on the phone who are
already seasoned data scientists I have
to walk a fine line you might find a
little bit of the stuff at the beginning
a little rudimentary but for those of
you who are not data scientists I think
this is going to be a good use of your
time it should be very easy to
understand what we're trying to do I'll
try to explain how things work I won't
go into too much detail on specifics of
code or anything like that but as
pointed out before you can always feel
free to reach out to me after the fact
so without further ado I think we'll
move forward now one of the major things
the data science tries to do is automate
the processes that we do every day and
so one of the things that I'd like to do
is try to help us predict breast cancer
so I've got my data science console up
here and you guys should be able to see
that and what I'm going to do is head
over to the community and I'm going to
look up the data set
and that data set is a breast cancer
data set that comes from the University
of California urban let's just put it in
here and I'll let you take a quick look
at it what you'll see is that in this
data set you've got a patient identifier
you've got a diagnosis of either benign
or malignant tumors and then we've taken
structured data that we've gathered from
the x-ray now some of you might be
thinking well you know data science on
highly structured data is easy teach a
computer how to recognize it from a
picture of an x-ray and that's what I'll
be talking about in the second portion
of this deep learning and convolutional
networks those types of things but to
set a baseline what I really wanted to
do is see if I could teach a computer to
recognize breast cancer the same way a
doctor would by looking at an x-ray so
you can see we've got about thirty two
columns we've got a few hundred examples
and these columns other than the
diagnosis are details that we've taken
from the x-ray for example if we see a
malignant tumor what's the texture of
that tumor what's the perimeter around
it how much area does it take up so
highly structured data so far so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to create a
project for this I've called it NIH
video now we are talking about scalable
data science so everything I'm doing
here you'll notice is written in either
Python or R and I create notebooks now
if you're not familiar with notebooks
IBM thinks that they are going to be
absolutely the sort of standard for how
we share an Alex analytic and code and
what's interesting about a notebook as
you can see here a notebook looks a lot
like a Word document
this particular notebook is a jupiter
notebook which again supports python r
SPARC Scala those types of languages and
what's interesting about them is that
you actually can write code and execute
code and pull data from these
so we'll be working in a notebook
environment today I won't make it pretty
for the sake of us actually getting
through the data science part of it but
if you are interested in taking a look
at what a professionally authored
notebook with professional data is you
can go take a look for again classifying
tumors with machine learning so one
thing I want to do is exploratory data
analysis so what I've done is I've
downloaded that data set that I pointed
out earlier breast cancer Wisconsin data
set so you can do your exploratory data
analysis wherever you want but I'm going
to just do it within the data science
experience here I can also show you how
you might do it with things like pixie
dust in Python but I want to generate
some basic metrics about things so first
of all we can see here that out of our
cases 357 were benign and 212 or
malignant which means that we've got a
slight imbalance of data there that's
probably something we'll need to take
into account and as we look across the
others we don't see any kind of a normal
distribution we just see data which is
kind of data so if we're trying to
predict the lot benign or malignant
you've got a couple of different options
you could go with an example would be a
logistic regression which is really good
at deciding between two binary things
but because of our data and how it can
be sort of non-linear nonparametric
we're going to go with a tree based
approach and i'll get into what that
means later if we needed to visualize
something we could do that here but what
I'm going to do is create a notebook and
I'm going to show you the steps you go
through to produce that model and then
we'll move again to the the deep
learning stuff so I'm going to create a
new notebook and I'm doing this
deliberately a little bit slowly so that
if you are following along you can do so
I'm going to call this predicting left
cancer I want to write in Python our
works just as well but
what I want to point out here is that
everything we're doing is running on
spark so underneath the covers we're
writing Python but it's executing as PI
spark or spark R and if you're not
familiar with spark it's incredibly
important to the Big Data space what
spark is is an engine which is in memory
which is distributed which is designed
to do a variety of different topics so
you could have spark do machine learning
you can do graph analytics which spark
you can do sequel like analytics but
today we're primarily going to be using
Python to do machine learning models so
the first thing I'm going to do is pull
in that data set that I just got so I
can do a header here we can say this is
my notebook and we're going through
predict cancer then add add a new cell
and we can get off to the races so
what's interesting about these is each
of these can be individually executed so
I need to pull in my data I'm going to
go over here to the data tab and
everything that you see in blue here by
the way is sort of unique to the data
science experience so there's some nice
things that appear around data
scheduling and collaboration but what I
want to do is insert my data set that I
have in this project as a panda's data
frame now by the way anybody that wants
to get access to this project just send
me an email and I can add you as a
collaborator you'll be able to see all
the code all the data and work with me
on it as we move now this code actually
generates some code which is really
slick but at the same time it shows my
password to me not to everybody else but
since we're recording this I'm going to
take a moment to pause the screen
generate my code and then I'll delete it
so I'm pausing the screen now
give me one moment please
I'm just making some adjustments to the
code so that we get a good data set and
then again we'll be good to go
okay hold on by the way if you're
interested in again following along you
can use let's see this beautiful
notebook that I'm about to put on the
screen over here while I'm generating my
code
so let's tell you what let's let's
actually walk through doing this the
old-fashioned way just so you can see it
so what I'm going to do is take my
breast cancer data set that you saw me
download earlier I put it in here in my
NIH video demo folder and I'm going to
drag and drop right onto my screen here
you'll see I've uploaded it you'll see
it appears down here there we go
and I'm going to create that notebook
again so we're going to call this
predicting
notebook and then do the code generation
there we go I'm going to run it and you
can see I have my data so again I've got
my identifier my diagnosis and then
other data set so how do we move forward
well the first thing I'm going to do is
rename this data file just to DF
something simple because I don't like
doing typing that every single times so
we're just going to re-execute this
alright now we move into the phase of
what's called exploratory data analysis
now I like to use a tool called pixie
dust to do this which is a Python tool
and to make sure that we've got the
proper libraries I'm going to install
Pixy dust here and we go it looks like
I'm good to go on that front I'm going
to tell my notebooks that I want to use
Pixy dust now that I've got it installed
so I import and now I can use the
display call so this is a function which
actually generates something similar to
what you might get with Excel or a tool
that does charts and graphs so I can say
I want to do a bar chart and I want to
do it based on I don't know we could do
the ID and we can do the diagnosis here
and so I can do some exploratory data
analysis in this way I can look at
distributions things like that now we
talked about this earlier I do have a
slight imbalance between malignant and
benign so what I'm going to start to do
now is leverage Python code to do a
decision tree so we've we've analyzed
our data here I'm going to show you that
grows 200 through 210 look very similar
and then I'm going to have Python do
some basic pre-processing for me so if
you haven't you Python for data science
this is one of the most important
packages available so I can't learn so
when I run this I'm going to go ahead
and do the install hopefully I've
already got it installed yes I do great
and now I'm going to do what's called
pre
setting so I'm calling that
pre-processing function from
scikit-learn and I'm doing what's called
a label encoder and if you look up here
you can see my diagnosis is either
malignant or benign but to a computer
it's easier for systems to understand if
it's a 1 or a 0 binary gone up so it
makes our processing faster and it makes
it easier to use certain algorithms so
the first thing I'm going to do is check
to see if any of my data is null because
that can cause problems I might have to
go back compute data that type of thing
doesn't look like it that's great I'm
lucky enough that this is a demo and I
can cheat a little bit I've got a nice
clean data set the last thing I'm going
to do is if I'm going to change this
data file this is the best practice I
like to create a new one so I'm going to
say that my original data file is equal
to this DF 2 just in case then I run
code to do the transition that I talked
about so we change that diagnosis field
to a 1 or 0 and then we do a describe so
this gives us a statistical sample of
what's going on in this data what
percentages are where you can see your
my diagnosis either 1 or 0 but it might
help me narrow down things like standard
deviations and if that's relevant later
on I don't see anything that scares me
here so what I need to do now to create
a valid model if segregate out some of
that data so there are multiple schools
of thought on this and we will cut this
later but I'm going to bring in a thing
here called Train test split and what
this does is it takes all of my examples
and it segregates out 20% of them in
this case you can see down there tests
I'd point to that 20% is set aside and
it's not used in my building of my model
so when I teach the computer how to
recognize breast cancer 20% of it does
not get taken into account and that way
I have a good way to test it later so
I'm going to run this code here and you
can see execute by the way you know if
it's executing that's got a little star
over there so what we're going to do
next is build a decision tree and this
Gentry's mimic human reasoning they're
very easy to understand and I think and
not quite as powerful in some cases and
some tools like deep learning tools but
they're very quick and they're very easy
so I need this to generate some graphics
here and I'll just make sure that I have
that installed great and then I'm going
to pull in the tree library so the tree
library in Python implements what's
called a c-45 decision tree and you can
see here that I'm saying don't use the
column identifier because the identifier
obviously is not relevant to say of
breast cancer or not and I've given it
the splitting columns so of course
taking a moment to talk about decision
tree to a little bit more and you'll see
exactly what I mean in a second as a
human we can reason for example how long
is it going to take me to get to work
today well you've got variables that go
into that like is it raining is it
Monday you live in DC all of those
affect an outcome decision trees are a
way for a computer a machine that's been
given an outcome like malignant or
benign to figure out which of the
features that you've given it affects
that outcome the most and then work
backwards so we're going to do this
processing here I'm going to run this
cell it gets executed and now what I'm
going to do is export this or the graph
so you'll be able to get a picture of
the tree that it just generated so you
can see here this is exactly the tree
there are many knobs to tweak when you
do decision trees and we're going to
spend a little bit of time actually
going over a lot of those but what you
can see is when you're concave points
mean is greater than or equal to what 0
for 9
and the rest of these functions we can
then determine if something is benign or
malignant
so when new datasets come in when I get
new data set the system had never seen
before I can simply walk the tree ask
the question yes or no I can get a
result really powerful stuff in terms of
implementing things like business rules
or being able to do multi class
associations and classifications so this
falls into the family of supervised
learning because we are giving the
computer an outcome and telling it to
particularly outcome of a new thing and
like I said decision trees are great
because they're easy to understand
they're very fast
they don't need necessarily normal
curves and data or things like that but
we can make it better so for those of
you who already know what a decision
tree is and how to tweak those this is
where it gets more interesting I think
for you let's interpret our tree so we
know what all these points mean
generally speaking especially if you're
a doctor but we need to evaluate the
model now remember we left out 20% or
data so what I'm going to do now is
import that 20% and test it I'm going to
use the predict functionality here out
of sight get learn metric to actually
say okay so for those 20% that we didn't
put in here how good is this model and
you can see the output right here so
your accuracy is 92% we guessed correct
92% of the time or 93 percent
surrounding au C stands for area under
the curve area under the curve has to do
with a statistical method of judging the
successful model called receiver
operating characteristic but for those
who don't know what ROC curves are you
can simply think of this is 93 percent
of the time we managed to catch the
malignant tumor now if you're like me
and you want to know if you have cancer
then 93 percent is pretty good
but it's not great there's still seven
percent of missed or miss misclassified
you could build something like a
confusion matrix here to show how
positive true positives that's easy to
do but instead what I'd like to do is
try to focus on improving this model so
this is our baseline here 93 93% 94%
that's pretty good
but it has its limitation so what I want
to do is use something called gradient
boosting so I'm going to use this thing
here called XG boost which is another
Python package and XG boost has become
very popular in things like casual
competitions because of how powerful it
is in predicting outcomes so we're going
to use the xgb classifier instead of the
traditional tree so I import that and
don't worry about this deprecation
warning but our version sit back a
little bit so in order to improve this
model we're going to use a couple of
different techniques we're going to tune
the parameters of the tree things like
gamma lambda tree depth child date
weight these types of things and we're
also going to use k-fold
cross-validation in this case 5 so to do
that I'm going to import cost validation
now the way cross-validation works is
it's a model used to measure how well
model generalizes when using the
training set and it divides it into even
smaller training sets to gauge how the
model performs undated hasn't seen
before so for example if we had 5
samples we could call them ABCDE we take
a model built on ABCD leave out e and
score it then I do the same thing for B
C D and E and leave out a and do this 5
time and the reason I do this is because
you could build a perfect tree if you
use 100% of your data but every time you
get a new data set you can't necessarily
that correctly because you over fitted
your tree so just like a normal tree
sometimes these types of trees need
paring back they need to be told
don't be so specific you need to be more
general that way I can go ahead and when
I get new data in I have a better model
so again we're cooking binary logistic
here because we're trying to pick
whether it's benign or malignant you can
leave these we can get into a detailed
discussion of some of these later if we
need to but I'm just going to set those
right now I'm going to do it three times
so I run this and we're now good to go
so what I'm going to do next is bring in
libraries to plot this out you'll see
here and then I'm going to build a
function and again I'm not going to go
into the specifics of the code here but
what's important here is that I've got a
function to evaluate the model it's
going to iterate over the data and it's
going to try to increase our area under
the curve and iterate and iterate and
iterate until it can't get any better so
when I run this piece here you'll see it
running in the background
and we'll call the function so again
don't use IV call the function evaluate
model use the training data the features
are what we've just described and
execute so you see here it's running
again and again and the area under the
curve is going up and up and up
significantly so what we figured out
here is that by using capable
cross-validation we're doing what's
called boosting the tree we're using
multiple trees in an ensemble to get a
better result so now we're doing pretty
well we've got a list of which features
are most important right these are the
things that a doctor would look at first
to determine if something is benign or
not and we've got a much better accuracy
and area under the curve but I think we
can even do better and this is where the
art of data science comes in I often
joke with my wife that it should be
called data art instead of data science
so we're going to do a couple of things
here to do what's called tune the max
depths and the child weight so the max
best of the tree is how many nodes can I
have and again you don't want a tree
that's super-complicated that overfits
to a data set so we want to figure out
what our max depth should be and we want
to figure out when if there is something
like this texture mean and clearly it's
off the charts in terms of importance in
predicting cancer that its importance
doesn't make the others less important
because there may be fringe cases where
the radius worst or the concave points
mean is far more important than the
texture mean fringe cases these types of
things so this is where the tuning part
comes in so in order to do this I'm
going to go ahead and build another
function here where here's our default
model but we use a thing called grid
search TV so it's cross validating again
it's going to run
it's going to sound fine that's the
model that works best as a max depth of
five and a minimum child weight of two
now I made a mistake here which is
always good during the last demo
I forgot the import grid search TV so I
need to go ahead and make sure that I
include from scikit-learn move that up
on that and now we shouldn't have a
problem you can see it's executing and
it will produce results in a moment
now another piece of the puzzle is
something called gamma so gamma
increases our sort makes the algorithm
more conservative which means it's less
prone again to overfit we'll see here by
the way that it went down up to 6 and
then back down to 5 and then determine
that child weight so the way we're doing
the scoring is that area under the curve
stuff so that's good now we have another
variable which we can add to our study
evaluate the gamma and the lambda we're
going to use this code here so we're
using our same evaluate model we're
including that math depth and child
weight which we just figured out from up
here
and we're going to execute that to see
excuse me I forgot piece of code here
let's not forget to figure out what the
Gama should be there we go
here's how we figure out the Gama so
again we're doing a test and to do this
we're iterating over the data now once
you get to very large data sets making
sure that you're using a scalable
technology underneath the covers like
spark is really important because as we
evaluate models we need to test
different models we need to test
different parameters and there are going
to be friends use cases where the
computer may see something that we don't
so what we've determined here is the
ideal gamma you can see that there we're
going to set the gamma in our original
classifier we're going to retest now see
how we're doing I would argue that we're
probably hopefully doing better
yeah so we're getting some really good
results now we're talking about 99 98
percent accurate similar features
importance that's to be expected so
there are more sampling parameters and
I've got a limited amount of time on the
call so I'm going to put the code here
so you can go check it out later if you
have access to data science experience
you'll be able to see this easily in the
sample models there but I'll run this
you'll get an output here's lambda and
alpha again we're adding tuning
parameters by using a very sort of
regular scientific process where we
execute tests execute tests and again it
takes a little bit of time to process
even when running in spark one of the
nice things about data science
experience is that it this is all free
everything you're seeing today is free
including the storage in the execution
but I can scale that up and down so if I
have a very large data set instead of
using two cores like I am on this I can
scale it to 300 cores or whatever I need
so that's kind of helpful so we'll let
these run and then finally we'll run our
final model because now we have a good
idea exactly what to use for Alpha Gamma
child weight the depth the number of
estimators and learning right how do you
think we're going to do pretty good I
hope so so we'll run this and here is
going to be our final prediction bring
in the data use this and spit out the
answer
so I think what we'll have at the end of
it is a model which effectively is
99.9999% accurate which is pretty good
if I'm a doctor I think that's a pretty
good rate for me identifying stuff or
not missing stuff especially malignant
cancer so we're much better than we were
that's the original right 98% and here's
where we are right now point nine nine
nine nine nine so pretty solid stuff
there to recap what we did is we got our
data set did you see there we made sure
we had library we did some basic
exploratory data analysis for the
purposes of a demo this is usually where
you spend a lot more of your time but
we're not going to do that today we did
some basic statistical descriptions and
then we started down the path of the
tree so we created a basic tree we
validated that that approach works which
is great and then we actually went and
created a more advanced tree by taking
advantage of a ensemble model a boosted
tree we then ran we use the code to
actually regenerate all the different
parameters to that function and then we
iterated over that to increase the score
for all of the different parameters that
we think are worthwhile so we started
out with a pretty good result and we're
going to end up with a great result now
there are some of you who are thinking I
don't know Python I don't ever want to
do this well we can do it automatically
- I'll take just 30 seconds to do this
but you can see here I've got the same
data set if I go over here to analytic
assets and cut tell the system to create
a new model I can do that as well so
we'll just call this new model
and you can find this type of technology
in a lot of modern examples of tooling
like spss modeler or SAS or those types
of things but effectively what we're
doing here is what I call Auto modeling
so I take in a data set it figures out
the hyper parameter optimization model
selection and then it gives me whichever
one scores the best so this would be for
somebody who doesn't ever want to touch
a keyboard doesn't want to go in your
Python you still have the option to be
able to do predictive analytics so in
this case select the column that you
want to predict diagnosis I want to use
all the columns it's a binary
classification and I want to do four
different models here that we can train
so in the background the system here is
doing everything that I just did
manually and it's going to do it
presumably pretty quickly but there are
options I view this as you could give
something like this to a doctor they
could evaluate if any of the models work
and then there's a handoff to a season's
data scientist who's going to go ahead
and run that code that you just saw so
what it's doing in the background here
is it's going to actually train and
evaluate all these different models do
the same types of things that we just
did in SPARC and actually spit out
performance and you'll actually see
which one's work best we use the
decision tree classifier and here it's
only getting it to about 92% for the aoc
we were able to do better as human being
and I think that makes us feel pretty
good about ourselves and so last but not
least we'll do let it do its gradient
boosted tree and turns out here that
random forest might actually be a really
good way to go so random forest is a
great technology for decision trees
where you're building sort of multiple
decision trees on each other so we do
have a model now where we can actually
deploy this and you know send data to it
anyway
so we've talked now about predicting
breast cancer and we've done it using
high
structured data and I mentioned before
some might say that that's cheating how
do we do this again unstructured data
well there's a there's a quote out there
which I like a lot which is in machine
learning
having that having more data is almost
more important than having better
algorithms
so I don't have images of breast cancer
lying around I could probably go find
some but what we're going to do here is
just to show the basics is show how a
different variety of machine learning
something called deep learning can be
trained to recognize handwritten digits
this is a classic example but if you
haven't seen it before it can be very
effective one thing to note here is that
deep learning is significantly more
computationally intensive usually than
traditional machine learning so I'm not
going to run this one interactively but
you can see the results from a previous
run so what is these learning compared
to the machine learning and a tree based
learning that we just talked about well
deep learning tries to simulate how a
human brain works and it has the
original ones were called neural
networks just like we have neurons so it
tries to make its own connections and
then it builds what's called the hidden
layers so a deep learning model can have
hundreds of layers and it will assume or
try to think about a problem the same
way a human think about a problem by
connecting ideas testing it out seeing
what works if it doesn't work it goes on
and creates a new hidden model now
that's a very rudimentary explanation of
deep learning I'm happy to go into some
of the math after this or maybe during a
different session but that's sort of
what you need to know for now and an
important part of a deep learning is
that we figured out that things like
graphics processing units GPU the same
thing that runs video games is actually
really good at doing matrix math and
deep learning Tennyson's love a lot of
matrix math so at IBM we are talking
about big data here when you need to do
deep learning against large amounts of
data or large streams of data you have
to use GPU so that's why cars that are
coming out now that are learning to do
image detection and find other cars and
people on the road are using GPUs
onboard so enough about deep learning
for the moment let's take a look at what
we're going to do here so I've got data
that I borrowed from Google of
handwritten digits so there's a large
database of these handwritten digits and
it's easy for a human to understand what
makes a 7 to 7 but it's actually very
difficult for a computer to read a
picture and understand within it
this is admittedly a simplistic example
because you could have a different
example might be show me pictures of
birds or show me pictures of cancer on a
lung x-ray but with that you're going to
have multiple different angles you can
have different locations for the cancer
so it's it's not as simple it's not as
black and white and we'll talk a little
bit about that more later anyway what
I'm going to do here is install a
package called no learn and no learn is
a Python package that does deep learning
in fact we're going to be using
something called a deep belief Network
and these belief networks are pretty
quick to execute against simplistic data
sets like this one so we're using it
here but we can talk about other
algorithms as well so as I step through
this I've got my sidekick learn which is
the same thing I had from my previous
example where I need to separate out
test and training you'll find that the
common theme throughout all data science
I've got metrics right so how does it do
data sets right so sample data set this
is the deep belief Network BBN and then
some Python math and other image stuff
we're going to pull in data from
tensorflow
and this is where we're pulling our
images and our labels so for every image
of a handwritten number nine
a label that tells the computer that
this is a nine it's worth mentioning
tensorflow because there are a lot of
libraries out there put out by different
companies and different open-source
groups things like chaos tensorflow
cafe torch these are all names that are
really powerful engine that are helping
people sort of do things like machine
vision and and that kind of thing but
it's a little bit difficult at the
moment to work with all of them at once
because there's no real standard for
that it's sort of the Wild West so
that's something that IBM is spending a
lot of time on is making sure that if
people want to use these things they all
work together and they all work together
in a similar fashion so in the data
science experience here we have
technologies like tensorflow built right
in so you can use them and you can
execute on GPUs and things like that
so right here I'm separating out my
training and tests just as we did before
as you can see here I'm leaving out 33%
not 20% so I've got a database about
37,000 or so images used for training
and then another 36,000 or so for
testing so that's pretty good all right
so now we need to train the pattern
recognition model if you want to get
into the very sophisticated map that
goes into some of this stuff I can
highly recommend you go to this link
there's a there's a bunch of data there
on how we do this but effectively what
we're doing here is we're telling the
deep belief Network solver which is this
BBN call here that it can go 300 layers
deep as we figured out that we think
that that's around the most optimal for
each of the 10 digits and that's that
time epochs here so this part takes a
while if you run it on your own
especially if you don't have GPUs to
accelerate it so each of these
represents the 300 layers for each digit
so it goes through all 10 digits
and if you were at the point where you
were trying to do something extremely
difficult to recognize like very small
cancers in x-rays that require
sophisticated technicians to read this
is where you would probably stray away
from a deep belief Network and move
towards something like a convolutional
neural network and convolutional
networks are better able to take into
account the entire picture and better
able to layer different angles different
you know versions of what the things
looking for because you know a cancerous
tumor looks completely different from
the side then it might from the front my
wife is spending a lot of time on this
actually right now doing some work for
the Transportation Security
Administration where they're trying to
automate the process of detecting people
walking through x-ray machines and
hiding metal or other weapons in their
clothes or in their bodies so really
application across the board on this one
good stuff there and what's interesting
about this now is my report so I call VB
end up predict against the training data
and you can see here my precision and
recall is great so I've built a model
where I've been able to actually teach a
computer to read handwritten digits and
I've done it I don't know if you've seen
but it's maybe less than 100 lines of
code because I'm able to take advantage
of some of these really sophisticated
packages and Python and are one of the
interesting things just as an aside
about this space right now is that all
of the really interesting stuff is
happening in the open source this
I think analytics is the shining example
of how open source can be the most
effective way to get data out there get
code out there and increase innovation
so IBM a while back even though we have
our own technologies like SPSS they're
not abandoning it but we're certainly
embracing how the accelerated process of
open source is really changing the world
so we're very excited about
and that's one of the reasons we built
this data science experience to make
that process easier so I'm going to
define a function here where I call it
random image so it picks it out it picks
a random image out of my entire data set
and tries to figure out what it is and
let's see how we do here so I know I ran
this before and it occasionally does
miss things but actual digit 7 predicted
is 7 pretty good oh we think it's a 5
definitely 5 there's a tricky one what's
that 7 it's a 7 so we're 100% in this
case not bad especially when they get a
little wonky like that I did not write
this notebook of course the people who
do write it are all listed here so some
of them are colleagues in academia
industry some of them are us
but here's an example again a very
simple example of how we can use deep
deep learning to do image classification
so we have Watson for oncology I'm sure
some of you have heard of this we've
spent years working with things like
convolutional neural networks with
Watson's natural language processing and
all that to get Watson the supercomputer
to be able to use this type of thing in
the background and actually recognize
cancer and then tell you what to do
about it what are the best forms of
treatment those types of things now
we're making pretty good time here I
think I've got a couple of minutes left
so I'll highlight some other
technologies that I think are really
fascinating and then I'll leave 10
minutes at the end for questions so one
of the other most important things that
I think we have to really focus on is
genomics I don't know if any of you are
in the genomics field but one of the my
favorite packages is something called
atom so if you go out there and you look
up Apache atom ABAM you'll see that
there is actually an open source
distribution that runs in spark meaning
highly scalable that's able to do
certain genomics tests now I am by no
means a geneticist here but what I'll
show you here is something called
counting Kaymer's okay Emmy arse
something that previously took I don't
know a year to do we can now do divide
and conquer spread across multiple
species or cloud systems and produce
tangible results so here if I say at n
where K is 10 it's looking for Strings
of 10 it's counting them and this is
actually doing it out of a mouse's
genome so this is something that's
obviously not as pretty as some of the
other stuff you've seen but it's things
we're working on an idea how do we work
with the FDA FDA if you look at the
genetics of certain trends or chemical
formulas break them down and do drug
safety type stuff so fascinating stuff
there again that technology if I give
them a plug is called atom 80 am and if
you're a geneticist I highly recommend
you look into it good stuff there and
the last piece that I'll bring up is
something which may seem trivial but
it's actually super important we all
work in environments where we have
constrained resources and so the other
side of predictive analytics is
something called prescriptive analytics
if I can predict you know that I'm going
to need a certain amount of a drug or
anything like that then I need to know
what to do about it next so this is
something that the classic computer
science problem called the nurse
assignment problem and here we're
combining Python with IBM's
resource optimization engine so I need
to schedule all these nurses together I
load in their data and they each have
specialties they each have vacation
times they each have costs associated
with them some of them are in different
locations some of them don't like each
other and won't work with each other
that's exactly what a prescriptive
analytics engine does if you give it
data about what you're trying to
accomplish and then you give it resource
constraints and we find the most optimal
way to do that scheduling or to have the
right drugs at right hospital at the
right time based on me these types of
things so a really important part of
predictive analytics something which can
be absolutely integrated in with the
open source technology like Python and R
and then built out so that you can
actually do these prescriptions or
Prescriptives analytics on the fly so
putting there you know right vehicles in
the right place this is something that I
personally spend a lot of time with with
logistics right that groups like the
Army Navy that kind of stuff so all that
being said I'm now at 12:50 I'd like to
invite my hosts to jump back on
hopefully he's not tapped out no no sir
Jonathan I'm not thank you so much for
that really great tour through the IBM
data science experience that was
fascinating we have a question where one
of our listeners was asking about how
the code defines the feature importance
score in your decision tree yeah great
question so let me go back to it for you
here when you do things like decision
trees you get feature importance because
it does well really want to two things
so this is something you can go and look
up later but it either uses what's
called a Gini index or an entropy score
and what it does is it determines
whether what the most important part of
that that data set is because it's able
to split the data based on it so let me
just bring up my my model here some part
of that library is what we were talking
about and I'll get down to the exact
spot but what it's realized here is that
this concave points mean
greater than or equal to this you're
almost always in a certain category
another easy
analog might be gender right if you're
trying to determine if somebody's a male
or a female you could use data like how
much do they weigh how taller they but I
think if you just looked at their 2d
ology that gives you hands-down the
biggest clue right maybe not all the
time but it's so an example of feature
importance there would be we're at the
root node of the tree and it's figured
out that pretty much anything to the
left or right is going to have a huge
impact on whether in this case it's
benign or cancerous so let's see the
actual code part that gives you that
output is right here so we're doing this
part of the algorithm we're getting the
score the feature score and then sorting
it by how high that score is so 10
obviously and then descending hopefully
that answers the question I will put up
my contact information so you can ping
me it if I didn't list it there but any
other question yes we do have a couple
other questions so someone is asking I'm
do you have any resources on choosing
the right machine learning model for
your particular question yeah and this
is where it gets that data art piece as
well so we have technologies that do
automatic modeling I showed you one of
them today we call that IBM machine
learning and what that does is it
separates out the obvious
you know technologies or sorry obvious
algorithms or models for a problem
because I'm just aren't appropriate for
certain things and then it will go
through and do subtle testing we call it
cognitive assistance for data science so
there are other technology platforms out
there that do that if you want to do it
the old-fashioned way
unfortunately it's sort of a an
understanding of the models and this is
where the art comes in so
you may understand that random forest
works really great for certain problems
but you've got more ability to tweak
algorithms or things there so a lot of
its going to be personal experience
unfortunately but we do have
technologies like Watson analytics and
Watson team learning that will go
through test a bunch of models and then
give you what it thinks is the strongest
solution so that's technology that's
been out for a while but again a lot of
it can be just based on personal
experience unfortunately right do you
see a lot of people interested in these
sorts of solutions who are working in
the area of clinical trials or in drug
discovery for example absolutely so we
do a ton with clinical trials clinical
informatics the drug discovery stuff I'm
not as strong on but we do do it there
when you think about it the platform is
a highly scalable inexpensive platform
where you can have it run either up in
the cloud or on your own site and that
alone is kind of nice because I can take
a data set and I don't have to pay a
million dollars to run through a
supercomputer and you have a huge amount
of flexibility and control by using this
open source stuff because there are
algorithms that come out for clinical
informatics out of certain research
institutions monthly right where I can
go download the latest and greatest
based on some paper I just read so we're
doing some of this at the VA right now I
know there are teams at the NIH working
in sort of small teams one of the
problems with the industry right now is
it's just a little immature it's a lot
like sort of business intelligence was
back in the 90s where everybody had
their own Excel spreadsheets on their
desktops so yeah we're trying to help
with that right get around some of the
governance problems bring people with
together with repeatable datasets and be
able to share the insight that they're
coming up with
yeah well that's that's fantastic and
one of the things that you had mentioned
in a couple of times sort of in passing
is everybody's kind of all familiar with
the Watson
supercomputing system and I'm curious if
this has exactly how this dovetails with
that or perhaps it doesn't at all but I
thought maybe if you could explain if
there was that would be very interesting
yeah great great question so there's
some core logic that Watson does that
helps us do things like understanding
language and intent and beliefs so what
you saw today is what we call our Watson
Data Platform
not that unstructured it isn't data but
it focuses much more unstructured data
and certainly on the open source so we
do use Watson within the Watson data
platform but it's fundamentally
different than the Watson that you see
on TV - plays jeopardy and things like
that right at Watson is less about
predicting the future using math and
more about interacting with humans and
understanding written word so when you
bring them together you get these nice
interfaces where I can bring in a
structured data set and I can ask a
question in regular old English and
Watson will understand that translate it
into a mathematical equation and then
we'll use some of these mathematical
techniques and open source analytics on
the back end to output the correct
answer so it's exciting time to be at
idea yeah that's interesting and of
course I could load my own data if I
wanted to if it were you know I'm doing
I do work in neuroimaging for example
and if I had not necessarily the raw
images but I had measurements made on
those images I presume I could load this
in as my own data source and then carry
on right absolutely so everything you
saw today is available up at data
science at
that's fantastic let's see what time do
we have here we only have like a couple
of minutes left but I don't see any
other questions flying in but anyway
maybe I'll take this time to once again
thank Jonathan Entwistle from IBM to
give us a rundown of the data science
experience it looks like very useful
very well-thought-out
very flexible and scalable solution for
dealing with a lot of our biomedical
data types and being able to to document
and and share that with others and other
colleagues so it sounds very exciting I
hope that those of you who are
interested will will reach out to
Jonathan with any additional questions
by his contact information check things
out at data science ibm.com or cognitive
class AI and learn more about it once
again this is our fundamentals of data
science seminar series and do watch for
in your emails for announcements about
our further sessions and our further
speakers and information about them and
once again let me thank Jonathan for his
lecture this morning and thank you for
joining us thank you very much everyone
have a wonderful day
thank you much